all right garden porsche las vegas has
gone electric and let's just say
i'll take a take on check this out
here at gotten porsche we have a vast
selection of cars of course new
pre-owned and we even have classic cars
porsche classic
we're actually the very first porsche
classic partner to be chartered
in north america we're very proud of
that but today we're really excited to
introduce
porsche's very first electric vehicle
the porsche tycoon
[Music]
this vehicle starts at 72 400
after the federal tax credits and that
is a price point that is pretty
reachable when it comes to luxury
electric vehicles
of course one of the first questions we
get is what is the range of the new
porsche tycon
and there have been a lot of answers
with that everywhere from the epa around
200 miles up to edmunds.com that got 323
miles
which was the largest distance and
improvement over the epa range
and there are many other estimates that
have happened around that range
but one thing that we found is that this
is a fantastic town to own an electric
vehicle
so if you're driving 30 miles 40 50
miles a day
and we're talking two or three hundred
miles should have plenty of charge to
get around for the day
and plenty of range so when it comes to
charging your car where are you going to
do it
so most of the time with people with a
gas engine they go to the gas station
well in the case of electric car your
gas station is probably in your garage
99 of your charging will be done at your
house or maybe at your place at work you
may have a charging station there
the porsche tycoon is the fastest
charging electric vehicle in the world
we're talking 100 miles of charge in
five minutes and 200 miles of charge and
only 22 and a half minutes
now i hear there are levels to this icon
right that's right rocky they're
actually four different levels of the
ticon the rear wheel drive that starts
around 400 horsepower
there's a 4s it's in the 500 range the
turbo with upper sixes but this my
friend
is the tycon turbo s with a modest 750
horsepower
there's a step above turbo that's
correct and we're looking at it right
here and there's only one way to truly
understand and experience something like
this and that is to do it for yourself
and so as you're about to see it's
available with a whole lot of
performance
oh my god so rocky one of my favorite
things about the tycon
is that although it's one of the best
performing porsches that's ever been
made
it's also exceedingly practical we're
talking four or five seat belts
available
two trunks plenty of cargo room so you
can still fit it into a practical
lifestyle while still having the
incredible high performance that porsche
is so famous for
you have a passenger display there right
in front of you and currently it's set
to media
you can do also navigation there and it
has a special setting called
cockpit which actually duplicates the
information that i have here as a driver
and then behind us in the rear seat
there's another touch screen for all the
climate control available to the rear
passenger there's a touch screen in the
back seat that's exactly right that's a
total of
five touchscreen goals
we're going to cost though i'm here for
you when it's time
to realize those goals and
put a dream into my driveway yes let's
put your dream into your driveway rocky
into my driveway fantastic i will take
it if you want a dream delivered to your
driveway give you out in porsche las
vegas a call at 702-383-6800 or visit
gardenporchlv.com for more information
we'll be right back right